SUPER-SPREADER’S OF HYPOCRISY.
LETS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANGLE.
HAVE YOU NOTICED THAT WHENEVER
THE MEDICAL EXPERTS SAY "THE
SCIENCE SAYS" AND ENDS UP
JUSTIFYING THE LEFT’S MOST
INSANE DEMANDS?
I CAN REMEMBER WHEN THE SCIENCE
TOLD US THAT TRUMP WAS
OVERREACTING BY BLOCKING TRAVEL
FROM CHINA AND I CAN REMEMBER
WHEN THE SCIENCE TOLD US NOT TO
WEAR MASKS.
I CAN ALSO REMEMBER WHEN THE
SCIENCE SAID THAT REOPENING
STATES EARLY WOULD MEAN
SKYROCKETING DEATHS IN THE
HOSPITALS WILL BE OVERLOADED.
WELL OF COURSE, THE SCIENCE
INVOKED BY THE SO-CALLED EXPERTS
WAS WRONG EVERY STEP OF THE WAY.
BUT THAT HASN’T STOPPED THE
MEDIA FROM BLARING ALARMIST
WARNINGS.
WELL NOW, "THE SCIENCE" HAS
DEEMED OKAY, ESSENTIALLY
ACTUALLY, TO PACK TOGETHER
OUTDOORS IN LARGE CROWDS TO
PROTEST IN THE NAME OF LIBERAL
POLITICAL CAUSES.
IN FACT, IT MAY BE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE COVID TREATMENT EVER.
>> IT WAS OUTDOORS WHERE THE
VIRUS IS MUCH MORE LIKELY TO BE
DISSIPATED INTO THE AIR.
ON THE OTHER HAND, PEOPLE WHO
WERE EXPOSED TO TEARGAS AND
SMOKE WHO ARE COUGHING WHICH WAS
MORE PREVALENT, WHICH IS DUMB --
IT DOES AEROSOLIZE THE VIRUS.
WE ALSO HAD PEOPLE WHO WERE
ARRESTED HELD IN VEHICLES SUCH
AS BUSES FOR HOURS BEFORE THEY
WERE PROTEST AND JAILS
OVERNIGHT, ALL WOULD INCREASE
TRANSMISSION.
BUT AS OF THIS MORNING, WE DON’T
YET HAVE ANY CONVINCING EVIDENCE
THIS HAS BEEN A BIG PROBLEM.
>> Laura: OKAY.
THAT’S WHAT WE MEANT BY HERD
IMMUNITY?
WELL, MEANWHILE, THAT SAME
SCIENCE CONSIDERS IT
UNACCEPTABLY DANGEROUS TO ATTEND
LARGE INDOOR GATHERINGS.
I’M SURE IT’S JUST A COINCIDENCE
THAT THESE SUPER-SPREADER EVENTS
HAPPEN TO EXACTLY MATCH THE
CAMPAIGN RALLY THAT TRUMP HAD
PLANNED OVER THE WEEKEND.
>> IF I WAS GIVING THE ADVICE TO
THE ADMINISTRATION ON THIS, I
WOULD SAY THEY SHOULD WITHHOLD
LARGE POLITICAL RALLIES RIGHT
NOW.
>> IT’S A BAD IDEA FOR STATES
ARE ALREADY SEEING ITS INCREASES
IN CASES TO THEN HAVE THESE
LARGE -- IT’S A PERFECT STORM
SET UP.
>> BEING IN A STADIUM WITH
POTENTIALLY 1 MILLION PEOPLE AS
THE CAMPAIGN IS SAYING, HAS
BOUGHT TICKETS, IS A SET UP FOR
A SUPER-SPREADER EVENT.
>> Laura: AND I’M SURE IT’S
JUST SHEER LUCK THAT THE
HYPERVENTILATION OVER A SECOND
WAVE OF COVID CASES CONVENIENTLY
TRACKS PRECISELY WHERE TRUMP IS
SET TO TRAVEL.
>> THOUSANDS WILL GATHER
SATURDAY NIGHT IN TULSA TO
LISTEN TO THE MOST FAMOUS
NONMASK-WHERE ARE THE COUNTRY.
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP.
BUT COVID IS HERE IN TULSA, IT
IS TRANSMITTING VERY
EFFICIENTLY.
CONFIRMED CASES IN THE COUNTY
JUST CLIMBED 30% IN A WEEK,
BLAMED BY THE HEALTH DEPARTMENT
ON LARGE INDOOR GATHERINGS.
>> Laura: REMEMBER, ITS
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND ICU BEDS
THAT REALLY COUNT.
BUT THAT’S ALL ALL RIGHT, JUST M
THE GOALPOSTS.
IF DEMOCRATS WISH THAT THE
PRESIDENT WOULD JUST PUT OFF
CAMPAIGNING INDEFINITELY,
OBVIOUSLY.
OR IDEALLY UNTIL AFTER THE
ELECTION OF JOE BIDEN, WHO, ALL
THINGS CONSIDERED MAY JUST
PREFER TO STAY IN HIS BASEMENT
UNTIL INAUGURATION DAY.
MEANWHILE, ANTHONY FAUCI A MAN
OBVIOUSLY SUFFERING FROM MEDIA
WITHDRAWAL, HE RESURFACED OVER
THE WEEKEND AND WHAT CAN ONLY BE
DESCRIBED AS A ONE-MAN EFFORT TO
DEPRESS US ALL.
NOW THAT WE ARE SLOWLY STARTING
TO GET OUR LIVES BACK EVER SO
SLOWLY, HE TOLD A BRITISH
NEWSPAPER, I WOULD HOPE THAT WE
COULD GET BACK TO SOME DEGREE OF
NORMALITY WITHIN A YEAR OR SO.
BUT I DON’T THINK IT’S THIS
WINTER OR FALL.
THE MEDICAL DEEP STATE STRIKES
AGAIN.
THE BOTTOM LINE FOR ALL OF US IS
THAT THE PRESIDENT AND HIS
CAMPAIGN SHOULD SIMPLY NOT REACT
TO ANY OF THIS ALARMIST DRIVEL
FROM HERE ON OUT.
NONE OF THESE PEOPLE, SADLY
INCLUDING DR. FAUCI, CAN BE
REALLY TAKEN ALL THAT SERIOUSLY
ANYMORE GIVEN WHAT WE’VE SEEN,
BECAUSE SCIENCE, JUST LIKE
JOURNALISM AND ENTERTAINMENT,
HAS BECOME OBSCENELY POLITICIZED
POLITICIZED.
WHY DID NONE OF THESE PEOPLE
WAILING ABOUT THE HEALTH HAZARDS
OF TRUMP’S FUTURE RALLIES VOICE
ANY REAL SUSTAINED CONCERN ABOUT
THE SHOULDER TO SHOULDER
PROTESTERS SCREAMING AT THE TOP
OF THEIR LUNGS, SOME NOT WEARING
MASKS, SOME TAKING THEM ON AND
OFF, CARRYING BLM ANTIFA OR
ANTI-TRUMP SIGNS, NO WORRIES,
WHY AREN’T THEY DECRYING THE
RISK A PICNIC THAT TOOK PLACE IN
CENTRAL PARK OVER THE WEEKEND?
MY FRIEND’S SON COULDN’T GET
MARRIED IN NEW ORLEANS, MY
HIGH SCHOOL BUT HE COULDN’T HER
DYING HER BROTHER BUT THEY FELT
FREE TO CONDUCT A RAVE OUTSIDE
OF D.C. MAYOR OF MURIEL BOWSER’S
HOME YESTERDAY.
[SINGING]
>> Laura: AT LEAST THERE WAS
SOME SOCIAL DISTANCING GOING ON
THERE.
CONSIDERING HOW MUCH MAYHEM
MAYOR BOWSER HAS LAMENTED IN
D.C., IS POETIC JUSTICE.
I WILL SUPPORT THE PROTESTERS ON
THAT ONE.
IN NEW YORK, GOVERNOR CUOMO
REPORTED JUST YESTERDAY 40 COVID
DEATHS, THAT’S A 96% DECREASE
FROM THE PEAK.
THAT’S GOOD NEWS.
BUT DESPITE ALL THAT AMAZING
PROGRESS, GOVERNOR CUOMO IS
STILL THREATENING BUSINESSES AND
LOCALITIES BECAUSE THEY’RE ALL
HAVING TOO MUCH FUN AND MAKING A
LITTLE MONEY.
WATCH.
>> I AM WARNING TODAY IN A NICE
WAY, CONSEQUENCES OF YOUR
ACTIONS.
WE HAVE 25,000 COMPLAINTS
STATEWIDE.
I’M NOT GOING TO TURN A BLIND
EYE TO THEM.
>> Laura: NOT LONG AFTER HE
ISSUED THAT THREAT, HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PROTESTERS FILLED
THE STREETS OF BROOKLYN.
A BLACK TRANS LIVES MATTER
RALLY.
ARE THEY GOING TO FACE
CONSEQUENCES?
FOR NOT SOCIAL DISTANCING OR NOT
WEARING MASKS OR NOT WEARING
THEM PROPERLY OR NOT WEARING
THEM LONG ENOUGH?
YOU GET THE POINT.
NOT FOR MAYOR BILL de BLASIO
THEY WON’T.
HE’S ORDERED THE CITY FOSTER
THIS VAST ARMY OF COVID CONTACT
TRACERS NOT TO ASK PEOPLE IF
THEY’VE BEEN PROTESTING.
WELL, THAT’S NOT TOTALLY TRUE,
de BLASIO DID PUNISH BROOKLYN’S
ORTHODOX JEWISH COMMUNITY FOR
THE HEINOUS CRIME OF GOING TO
THE PARK.
FOR THEIR SINS, de BLASIO SENT
CITY WORKERS TO WELD SHUT
ENGAGED IN THE JEWISH COMMUNITY
OF BOROUGH PARK IN BROOKLYN
TODAY.
THE ONLY THING THAT SHOULD BE
SHUT DOWN AT THIS POINT ARE THE
DEMOCRATS’ POLITICAL
FUND-RAISING OPERATION GIVEN
WHAT’S GOING ON HERE.
THEY NEED TO BE PUNISHED AT THE
BALLOT BOX FOR HOW BADLY THEY
BOTCHED THIS FROM DAY ONE.
AND AT THE SAME TIME,
PRESIDENT TRUMP MUST CONVEY A
CALM AND CONFIDENT MESSAGE.
I DON’T KNOW, SOMETHING KEEP
CALM AND WASH HER HANDS, DON’T
SNEEZE ON PEOPLE.
NOW IT’S BACK TO WORK FOR THE
REST OF US.
GOT TO GET OUR COUNTRY BACK.
HE MUST ALSO NOT ALLOW STATES TO
UNFAIRLY PUNISH THEIR OWN
RESIDENT FOR LESS WITH THESE
LONG FREEZE OUTS OF BUSINESS.
AT SOME POINT, THESE SHUTDOWNS
ARE TANTAMOUNT TO A STATE TAKING
OF PROPERTY WITHOUT DUE
COMPENSATION.
YOU SEE THE CONSTITUTIONAL
ARGUMENT I’M MAKING.
AND THAT’S A VIRUS OUR AMERICAN